there is a human way to help our
homeless community this summer season
that's right well the las vegas fashion
council and the southern nevada burn
foundation
will be teamed up for a flip-flop drive
and rocky theos is live at a local fire
station
to tell us all about it hey rocky
hey christian yeah we are at firehouse
29 and actually this is their very first
flip-flop drive here so this is really
exciting we're helping the community
we want 800 flip-flops but we're already
well above that so let's start with the
las vegas fashion council carrie
what are we looking for what kind of
flip-flops uh we're looking for
flip-flops of all sizes for men women
and children
predominantly sizes eight to ten for
women and ten to twelve for men so that
we can fit a variety of sizes
obviously bland brand new for sanitary
purposes
and they can be uh picked up anywhere
these particular pairs from old navy you
can get them at the 99 cent store your
corner
grocery store anywhere anywhere and very
easy to donate these are
not these are affordable okay that's all
i can say they're affordable
um so tell us why the las vegas fashion
council is involved
yes so we partner with a different
non-profit every single month and this
month we were presented with the
opportunity to partner with the burn
foundation we thought it was a
a great opportunity to give back to our
community especially given the heat and
the issues that we have with the
the level of the payment pavement
temperatures and
uh the burn foundation um came up with
this great idea to do the flip-flops so
we're combining um their organization
with ours and incorporating fashion and
it benefits our homeless population it's
the perfect marriage so let's move over
here to keith with the burn foundation
now she mentioned the pavement 110 maybe
give or take outside but the pavement
itself is about
130 right that is correct i mean as the
temperature raises
the pavement's going to raise and that
only does one thing for especially our
homeless population it's going to burn
their feet i mean these little things
right here
can save somebody's lives can save
somebody's feet just for a dollar
so these are uh what can i say save
somebody's feet by buying a pair of
flip-flops
easy is that easy as that and of course
this drive is going to
the 21st of june but that's not the last
day you can donate right we're asking
for your help
all year round correct i mean even
though the flip-flop drive ends the 21st
this is something that's going to be
going on for all of summer i mean
it's nice to have a backup stock of
flip-flops in case we need them in an
emergency
definitely and what's your website for
the burn foundation website
theburnfoundation.org
and that's where you can find out all
the locations that you can drop off so
i'm going to go ahead and toss mine in
there
and i will send it back to you all right
that is such a simple thing as she was
saying and can make such a difference
yeah awesome and then especially right
now with the summertime i mean who
doesn't have some extra just flip-flops
that you can kind of maybe just donate
yep